En la clase de hoy quiero
que pasemos a un tema
relacionado con el que veíamos
antes de las vacaciones de marzo.
Recordarán que antes de las
vacaciones analizábamos
las relaciones que se
establecen entre las personas
en lo que respecta a la
responsabilidad moral.
Podrían considerar que la primera parte
del curso, sobre la prosperidad,
se trataba de los seres
humanos como individuos
y de las formas en las que,
dentro de sí mismos,
podrían alcanzar cierto
tipo de armonía.
La segunda parte de curso se
trataba de la moralidad,
de las relaciones
interpersonales entre
individuos.
Y la tercera parte del curso,
que veremos a conciencia la
próxima semana,
se trata de cómo las estructuras
políticas pueden cultivar
ciertos tipos de
comportamientos en los
individuos.
Obviamente, eso es una idealización.
Los individuos
considerados en
aislamiento
siempre están interactuando con otros.
Los individuos en relaciones de parejas
siempre están arraigados en
comunidades más grandes.
Pero el enfoque del curso ha
pasado de individuos
a pequeños grupos y
posteriormente a grandes
grupos.
Y la unidad del castigo,
conformada por 2 clases,
es una unidad de transición
entre la sección de moralidad y la
de filosofía política.
Para arrancar,
para que recuerden las
preguntas que veíamos,
comenzaré con unas cuantas
preguntas para votar.
Espero que no hayan perdido sus
clickers en las vacaciones.
Les pediré que piensen en unos
casos de la vida real
que por desgracia tienen la
estructura del problema del tranvía.
Después, pasaremos a algunos casos
más directamente
relacionados con el castigo.
Recordarán que dedicamos
tiempo suficiente a pensar
en un caso abstracto e
idealizado de un dilema moral,
que a veces se conoce como el caso
del transeúnte del tranvía.
Hay un tranvía que está a punto de
chocar contra 5 personas.
Al costado hay un
transeúnte que se da cuenta
de que hay una vía alternativa
donde solo hay una persona.
Ese transeúnte tiene la opción de
desviar la amenaza, el tranvía,
de la vía donde hay 5 personas a
la vía donde solo hay 1.
Por desgracia,
el mundo se ha enfrentado a algo
similar al caso del tranvía:
la efusión de nubes radioactivas
de la planta de energía
nuclear japonesa.
La primera pregunta es:
supongamos que ustedes son el
Primer Ministro japonés
y que fuera evidente que la nube
radioactiva se dirigiera a Tokio,
que tiene una población de 13
millones aproximadamente,
y que tuvieran la posibilidad
de desviarla al campo,
a una zona con una población de 1
millón aproximadamente.
La pregunta es:
1) ¿Sería moralmente obligatorio
redirigir la columna de humo de los 13
millones al millón de personas?;
2) ¿Estaría moralmente permitido,
pero no sería moralmente obligatorio?;
o 3) ¿Estaría moralmente prohibido?
Veamos los resultados. Queda 1 segundo.
Veamos. El 31% piensa
que sería moralmente
obligatorio redirigir,
el 56% piensa que estaría
moralmente permitido
y el 13% piensa que estaría
moralmente prohibido.
Permítanme enseñarles lo que pensaban
cuando les hice esta pregunta
de forma abstracta,
como un simple problema de tranvía.
Ha subido al doble.
Vean estos resultados, el 31%
a diferencia del 15%
piensa que en el caso real
es moralmente obligatorio
redirigir la columna de humo.
Es muy interesante. Es
interesante metodológicamente.
Es interesante preguntarnos por
qué responden distinto
en un caso del mundo real y
en uno hipotético.
También es interesante
metodológicamente ver que
en la opción de prohibido los
resultados son casi idénticos.
El 15% pensaba que estaba
prohibido en el caso imaginario.
El 15%, en realidad el 13%
pensaba que estaba
prohibido en el caso real.
Parece que de cierta manera estos
casos imaginarios siguen,
en su abstracción, el mismo
tipo de consideraciones
que los casos reales en unos
aspectos, pero en otros no.
Los animo a que en las secciones
y en las conversaciones entre ustedes
piensen a qué se debe esto.
Además de ser un claro
ejemplo de tranvía,
un caso tradicional del transeúnte,
el caso de la tragedia nuclear en
Japón también tiene algo
en común con un caso que podríamos
llamar el camino del daño.
Recordarán que el segundo
tipo de problema
de tranvía que analizamos era un caso
donde el tranvía se dirigía
a toda velocidad hacia 5 personas y
encima de la vía había
otra persona que podíamos poner
en el camino del daño
para evitar la muerte de las otras 5.
¿Cómo podría encajar esto
con la situación real
a la que nos enfrentamos ahora?
Mismo accidente nuclear,
mismo primer ministro,
mismos 13 millones de
personas, pero ahora,
como Primer Ministro se enfrentan a
la posibilidad de reclutar
a un pequeño grupo de ingenieros
para una muerte segura,
cuyo trabajo permitirá
recuperar la electricidad
o verter agua en lugares
inaccesibles por la radioactividad
a cualquier persona que no fuera
enviada a una muerte segura.
Individuos que están en la posición
de salvar a 13 millones de personas,
mediante el sacrificio de un
pequeñísimo grupo de personas.
La pregunta es: Supongan que
el Primer Ministro
debe reclutar a los trabajadores
porque la planta está a punto de
explotar y liberará una enorme
cantidad de radiación a una
gran cantidad de personas.
1) ¿Sería moralmente obligatorio?;
2) ¿Estaría moralmente permitido,
pero no sería moralmente obligatorio?;
o 3) ¿Estaría moralmente
prohibido reclutar a trabajadores
para enviarlos a una muerte segura?
Los resultados aquí son
sumamente interesantes,
verán cuando los comparemos
con el caso abstracto.
Aquí el 27% dice que está prohibido,
el 41% dice que está
permitido pero no prohibido,
perdón el 41% dice que está
permitido pero que no es obligatorio,
y solo el 32% piensa que
estaría moralmente prohibido
reclutar a los trabajadores para
enviarlos a una muerte segura.
¿Cuáles fueron sus resultados en
el caso del hombre gordo?
Sin duda, eran muy distintos.
Solo quiero que vean sus resultados
en el caso real.
Más o menos el 32% pensaba
que estaba prohibido,
pero más del doble pensaba
que estaba prohibido
en el caso del hombre gordo.
Se debe a que, como sugiere Josh Greene,
cuando una situación es
cercana y personal,
¿imaginarse empujando a
alguien juega un papel,
como una heurística moral
legítima o ilegítima?
Mientras que en el caso donde se
imaginan reclutando a trabajadores,
¿les parece más distante
en términos del camino del daño en
el que colocan la situación?
¿La diferencia se debe a que en el
caso de los trabajadores
se percibe más como un
daño estadístico?
Y como sugiere Cass Sunstein,
¿nos cuesta más trabajo procesar
los daños estadísticos?
¿La diferencia en su respuesta al
caso del Primer Ministro
se debe a que la cantidad de 13 millones
comparada con una cantidad
menor cambia el análisis?
Pero si las cantidades
cambian el análisis,
entonces su respuesta no estaba motivada
por un derecho inviolable en el
caso del hombre gordo.
Quienes están entre la mayoría
que cambió de opinión,
-noten que la opción de
obligatorio subió,
la de prohibido bajó y la de
permitido subió-,
quiero que piensen en qué tipo
de razonamiento moral
explica la diferencia en sus
respuestas al caso real
del Primer Ministro y al caso
imaginario del hombre gordo.
Como siempre, pondré estas
diapositivas en la red
para que puedan analizar los
datos con detalle.
Los casos que hemos
considerado hasta ahora,
donde los terremotos ocasionan
desastres naturales
que provocan grandes daños a la
gente, son tragedias.
Pero son tragedias en las
que es difícil saber
hacia dónde dirigir nuestro
descontento con el estado del mundo.
No podemos hacer casi nada
para prevenir los terremotos.
Aunque se pueden tomar
precauciones con respecto a cosas
como las plantas de energía
nuclear, también hay factores
del mundo sobre los que muy
difícilmente podríamos ejercer
control.
Justo antes de las vacaciones de
marzo estábamos viendo,
en el contexto de la suerte moral,
casos donde las malas acciones
que nos interesaban
no las ejecutaba un agente impersonal,
como un terremoto, sino un individuo.
Por ejemplo,
los 4 casos de los conductores que
iban del trabajo a su casa.
Atento Afortunado que solo
manejó a su casa;
Atento Desafortunado que
manejó a su casa atento
pero atropelló a un niño;
Celular Afortunado que manejó a su
casa hablando por teléfono,
algo que ustedes nunca hacen;
y Celular Desafortunado que manejó a
su casa hablando por teléfono
y atropelló a un niño.
Les voy a mostrar 2 de sus
resultados anteriores
y después les haré otra
pregunta para votar.
Casi todos, el 95%, pensaban
que Atento Afortunado
no hizo nada reprobable al
manejar a su casa.
Recuerden que estipulamos
que no hablábamos
de cómo su huella de carbono
podría contribuir
a varios tipos de problemas mundiales.
El tema era solo si había
hecho algo malo moralmente
al manejar a su casa y el 95%
respondió que no.
Por el contrario, el 92%, casi todos,
pensaban que Celular Desafortunado,
el que hablaba por teléfono y
atropelló al niño,
hizo algo reprobable moralmente.
Saquen sus clickers porque
quiero preguntarles
si Celular Desafortunado,
la persona que hablaba por
teléfono y atropelló al niño,
hizo algo que merece un castigo.
Con esto pasaremos al tema principal
de nuestra discusión de
hoy y del jueves.
¿Celular Desafortunado hizo
algo que merece un castigo
por manejar a su casa
hablando por teléfono y,
desafortunadamente, atropellar al niño?
Veamos los resultados. El 94%,
incluso más de los que pensaban
que había hecho algo malo,
piensan que merece un castigo.
¡Qué buenos alumnos!
[risas]
En las próximas 2 clases quiero
analizar seriamente con ustedes
este desconcertante fenómeno
filosófico y psicológico.
El hecho de que cuando
alguien hace algo malo
y percibimos que la persona o el
autor de la mala acción
tuvo cierto tipo de responsabilidad,
existe, a través de las
culturas y el tiempo,
una tendencia a pensar que ese
individuo merece un castigo.
En la clase de hoy quiero
hacerles 3 preguntas.
Primero quiero presentarles
una caracterización clásica
del castigo civil,
para hacernos una idea de lo
que estamos hablando,
y les presentaré un resumen
que Pojman expone
en la lectura que les dejé para
hoy, que es de un trabajo
de mediados de los 50 sobre la
teoría legal analítica.
Veremos a qué nos referimos
cuando hablamos del
castigo penal o civil.
Después, quiero pasar a la principal
cuestión filosófica del castigo:
¿Cuál es la
justificación del
castigo?
Y verán, como ya habrán
notado en las lecturas,
que 2 de las principales
justificaciones que se ofrecen
para el castigo en realidad hacen eco
a 2 de las principales justificaciones
para las restricciones morales.
Es decir,
que podemos dar una explicación
utilitaria para el castigo
o una explicación deontológica.
Intentaré ubicarlos
en el modo de pensar de ambas
concepciones del castigo,
para ayudarlos a pensar sobre el castigo
y para ayudarlos a pensar,
más claramente,
en algunas cuestiones de
filosofía moral
que veíamos antes de las vacaciones.
Por supuesto, no solo les voy a
presentar estas visiones,
sino que intentaré que piensen
por qué son justificaciones racionales
o irracionales del castigo.
La siguiente clase veremos
algunos textos psicológicos
muy interesantes que,
con respecto a las teorías
deontológicas y utilitarias del
castigo
que estamos viendo hoy desde el
aspecto filosófico,
hacen lo que algunos textos de
literatura moral empírica
hicieron con respecto a la deontología
y al utilitarismo en general.
Es decir, que proponen el
sustrato psicológico
para nuestras reacciones y
en algunos casos
intentan argumentar que eso hace que
las reacciones sean ilegítimas.
O ilegítimas como una base para
cierto tipo de juicio normativo.
Quiero considerar esto
como cuestiones acerca del castigo
y como formas de pensar
más generalmente en la crítica
psicológica práctica de la teoría moral
que vimos la clase pasada.
Por último, en la siguiente
clase quiero que pensemos
en la relación entre el
castigo en el contexto civil
y el castigo en un contexto
mucho más personal.
Habrán visto que una de las cosas
que vamos a leer para el jueves
es otro capítulo de la guía
para padres de Alan Kazdin,
que yo considero inspirada
en Aristóteles.
Permítanme hacerles una advertencia:
el tema del castigo es enorme.
Podría haber todo un curso
sobre este tema.
Lo que les estoy presentando en
esta clase es una idea
angloamericana bastante básica
de qué es el castigo.
Quienes hayan analizado el castigo
en el contexto de la teoría social
habrán visto algunas críticas
sofisticadas al castigo
que provienen de la tradición
filosófica occidental del siglo XX,
en gran medida a través de los
textos de Nietzsche y Foucault.
Por falta de tiempo, no porque
no sean interesantes,
de hecho son sumamente interesantes,
pero no abordaremos a estos
escritores en esta clase.
Como siempre, estaré encantada
de hablar con ustedes
en horario de oficinas o en otro
momento acerca de esto.
Comencemos con la primera
de estas preguntas.
¿Qué queremos decir con castigo civil?
Cuando votaron
que Celular Desafortunado,
el hombre que había matado
accidentalmente al niño
mientras hablaba por teléfono,
merecía un castigo,
me imagino que pensaban en algo
que tuviera las 5 características
de los ejemplos
paradigmáticos del
castigo,
y tal vez consideran que son
condiciones necesarias
y suficientes para que algo sea
considerado un castigo.
La primera característica,
tal vez la más destacada cuando
pensamos en el castigo,
es que un castigo es algo que implica
cierto tipo de sufrimiento o disgusto.
En la cultura tradicional,
el castigo implica causar algún
tipo de dolor físico,
algún tipo de aislamiento social
o algún tipo de humillación pública.
Todo lo anterior implica una
situación desagradable o dolorosa.
En la sorprendente
descripción de los 3
caballos
en el Fedro de Platón, que
leímos al inicio del semestre,
el auriga, en su esfuerzo por dirigir
al obstinado caballo salvaje,
jala el freno del caballo y le
saca sangre de la boca
en su intento por castigarlo.
La noción central es que el castigo
implica sufrimiento y disgusto.
Implica llevar a alguien a un
estado perjudicial.
En lo que respecta al felicific
calculus, el cálculo de la felicidad,
la enumeración de la cantidad de
felicidad en el mundo,
el castigo reduce en ese individuo
la cantidad de felicidad que tiene.
Segunda característica.
El castigo no es solo la imposición
de un dolor o sufrimiento
en un individuo.
Es la imposición de un dolor o
sufrimiento en un individuo
a consecuencia de una
infracción en particular.
Una infracción legal, en el
caso del castigo legal.
O si consideran que el castigo es algo
que puede imponerse con
respecto a pecados morales,
en respuesta a una infracción moral.
No se trata solo de imponer
dolor al azar en el mundo.
Se trata de imponer dolor en el mundo,
como respuesta a una infracción legal
sobre la persona que la ha cometido.
No se trata de que si algo
malo pasa en un lugar,
encuentren a un individuo y
lo hagan sufrir.
El individuo al que se le
impone el sufrimiento
debe ser juzgado, por
cualquier procedimiento
que se considere legítimo
para dichos juicios
y debe ser considerado un infractor.
Además, el castigo lo debe administrar
un agente humano intencionadamente.
No basta con que las fuerzas naturales
de alguna manera provoquen las
malas consecuencias.
Hablaremos de esto más adelante,
con un problema de un caso de
castigo retributivo.
Por último, no se impone o
administra por un individuo
que actúe por su propia cuenta ni
por un grupo de individuos
que hayan tomado la justicia
en sus propias manos,
sino por una autoridad legal que tenga
la autorización del Estado
o de una institución civil.
La pregunta que plantea el castigo,
y lo volveremos a ver cuando
empecemos a analizar
la teoría política de
forma más general,
es cómo puede justificar un Estado
el causar daño a uno de sus miembros.
¿Cómo podría ser legítimo que una
sociedad causara un sufrimiento
o una situación desagradable a
uno de sus individuos?
Hay 2 tipos básicos de
justificación para el castigo.
La primera es una justificación
con visión de futuro.
Afirma que el castigo es un
mecanismo efectivo
para evitar un daño futuro.
Cuando alguien viola las
normas legales o sociales,
es probable que ese individuo
vuelva a actuar así.
Y es importante impedir que lo haga.
O cuando alguien viola las
normas legales o sociales
y otras personas ven que ese individuo
no recibe ninguna consecuencia negativa
de parte de la comunidad como
respuesta a su acto,
otras personas podrían
comportarse así.
Por eso, el castigo realiza una
función de disuasión pública.
Independientemente de cómo
se operacionalice,
hablaremos un poco de esto al
final de la clase,
la motivación básica para la
justificación con visión de futuro
es que el castigo es un medio efectivo
para evitar un daño futuro.
De cierta manera, el
sufrimiento de un individuo
que es castigado en nombre del Estado
se compensa con los beneficios
para otros individuos,
dichos beneficios serán el resultado
de haber causado daño en un individuo.
El perjudicar a alguien se
traduce en utilidad.
El segundo tipo de
justificación para el
castigo...
Quienes se quedaron
insatisfechos con la primera,
pero frustrados con Kant
en la discusión de teoría moral
antes de las vacaciones,
tienen que pensar en cómo encajar
sus visiones del mundo.
La segunda justificación dice que
el castigo es necesario,
porque cuando alguien viola los
códigos morales o legales
merece una sanción.
La justificación no es que sea una
forma de evitar un daño futuro,
aunque podría ser que eso pasara,
que hubiera ese agradable
beneficio adicional.
La razón por la que un
individuo será castigado
bajo esta justificación es porque al
violar una regla moral o legal,
dicha persona ha violado un
código legal o moral
y merece ser castigada por ello.
Esas son las 2 justificaciones
que vamos a analizar.
Pero quiero señalar que hay otra forma
de pensar acerca del castigo,
de la que hablaremos un
poco en esta clase,
me refiero a que podríamos
considerar el castigo
como una respuesta a un
trastorno del orden social,
donde por lo menos tienen que
participar 2 individuos.
Por un lado, la víctima,
la persona que se desea restablecer
al estado antes del daño.
Algo importante que debemos pensar
en el contexto del castigo
no son las represalias ni la disuasión,
aunque ambas cosas son
importantes para el individuo
como un miembro de la sociedad,
pero en el caso de este
delito específico
queremos pensar en el restablecimiento.
¿Qué podemos hacer
para que el individuo vuelva a su
estado antes del daño?
En el caso del infractor
podríamos pensar
en cómo restablecer a ese individuo
a un estado antes del daño
en un sentido más amplio y
global, es decir,
hacia una situación de prosocialidad.
Veamos estas 4 ideas con un
ejemplo específico.
Aquí está nuestro viejo amigo Giges,
¿recuerdan que lo conocimos en enero?
Ahí está y ahora le hemos
dado un caballo.
Giges tiene un caballo.
De pronto, aparece Pedro,
el malo en la historia de
Jim y los indios,
y se roba el caballo de Giges.
¿Qué se debe hacer?
Si nos interesa restablecer la
situación a su estado antes del daño,
entonces nuestra principal
preocupación es la devolución.
Queremos que Pedro le regrese
el caballo a Giges.
Supongamos que en vez de
robar el caballo,
Pedro lo hubiera matado.
Podríamos pensar que la
devolución exige que Pedro
le entregue algo del mismo
valor que el caballo.
Tal vez, Pedro debe dar uno de
sus caballos a Giges.
Pero la idea detrás de la devolución,
resulta problemática porque
el restablecimiento
a un estado antes del daño
es un poco más complicado
cuando no se trata solo
de regresar la propiedad robada o de
reemplazarla de alguna forma.
La noción detrás de la devolución,
la meta que le interesa al
Estado de forma legítima,
es garantizar que la parte inocente
no esté peor después de haber
sido víctima de un delito.
¿Qué nos pide hacer la noción de
rehabilitación en este Estado?
Aquí está Pedro con su cayado.
Supuestamente, tenemos que pensar en
cómo podemos ayudar a alguien, cuyas
interacciones con la sociedad
implican violaciones a sus normas,
para que interiorice esas normas
y le sirvan de base para
su comportamiento.
De cierta manera, la rehabilitación
es el medio más efectivo
para la disuasión y la prevención.
Si es posible reincorporar
la actitud prosocial
en los individuos en los que
estamos demostrando
nuestra preocupación a
través del castigo,
¿no sería ese el medio más efectivo?
Esa es una versión para
analizar lo que está pasando.
Podríamos pensar en la
devolución para el dañado
y la rehabilitación para
quien causó el daño.
O bien, podríamos analizar la
cuestión en términos
de las 2 categorías que veremos
en el resto de la clase.
Es decir, podríamos encerrar a
Pedro con la justificación
de que eso evitaría que cometiera
un crimen en el futuro.
Podríamos encerrar a Pedro
-miren la diapositiva porque es la
única broma de toda la clase-
pensando que al encerrarlo estamos
proporcionando justicia.
De hecho, hay otro gráfico chistoso
más adelante en la clase
sobre las formas en las que es parte
de nuestra cultura popular,
de nuestros dibujos animados, de
nuestros cómics y de las películas
que de alguna manera la imposición de
justicia sobre un infractor
es completamente crítica para el
bienestar de la sociedad.
Quiero presentarles estas 2
justificaciones, por un lado,
desde una visión interior con
el trabajo de Kant,
y por otro lado, de forma más general,
a través del trabajo de Rawls.
Comencemos con la visión retributiva.
A grandes rasgos, es la visión
de que cuando alguien
hace algo que viola las
normas legales o morales,
ha hecho algo incorrecto
y al hacerlo ha desequilibrado la
balanza de la justicia.
Y el castigo reorienta las
normas de la justicia,
vuelve a equilibrar las cosas.
Al castigar a quien hizo un
daño, reorientamos el mundo
de tal forma que la injusticia
se vuelve a ponderar
y la persona que hizo el daño
recibe su merecido.
El texto que leímos al discutir
el panorama retributivo
era de Immanuel Kant.
Kant escribe explícitamente:
"el castigo jurídico nunca
puede administrarse
solo como un medio para
promover otro medio,
ya sea con respecto al propio
delincuente o a la sociedad civil".
Es decir, que la disuasión, la prevención
del daño futuro y la rehabilitación,
que son otros bienes,
bien podrían venir con el castigo.
Pero esa no puede ser la
justificación del castigo.
Kant dice: "El castigo jurídico solo
se puede imponer a individuo
porque ha cometido un delito".
Este fragmento presenta la
visión más general de Kant.
Recordarán, en las primeras páginas
del libro de Fundamentación,
que a Kant no le interesa pensar
en las consecuencias.
A Kant le interesa la rectitud moral
y la forma en que nuestros
comportamientos
y nuestras instituciones sociales pueden
reflejar nuestro reconocimiento
de este hecho fundamental del mundo.
Quienes estén de acuerdo con la idea
de que los delincuentes
merecen su castigo,
no por razones utilitarias
sino fundamentales,
necesitan pensar si eso conlleva
un compromiso consciente
con el panorama kantiano más general,
donde la buena voluntad no es buena
debido a las cosas que afecta
o cumple, sino que es
buena en sí misma.
Esa es la visión central del
panorama retributivo.
El panorama retributivo ofrece
una respuesta a la pregunta
de cuál es la
justificación del
castigo.
Y la respuesta es dar un merecido moral.
Pero también ofrece una
explicación, que leímos para hoy,
de lo que Kant llama el "principio y
estándar de la justicia pública".
Es decir, que el retribucionismo
no solo incluye la idea
de que los delincuentes
merecen un castigo,
sino también una imagen de los
fundamentos para el castigo,
y a veces una caracterización
de lo que incluyen esos
castigos específicos.
Kant escribe: "el mal inmerecido que
alguien hace a otra persona
debe considerarse como un mal
hecho a sí mismo".
La idea de Kant se basa en una
justificación con principios,
es decir, el castigo debe ser igual
al daño cometido.
Continúa: "Quien roba hace que todas
las propiedades sean inseguras.
Por consiguiente, se roba a sí mismo
en seguridad de la propiedad,
según el derecho de represalias".
El castigo del robo es la pérdida
de la propiedad, dice Kant,
bajo el principio de que el mal
inmerecido que alguien hace
a otra persona debe considerarse
como un mal hecho a sí mismo.
La lógica de ese argumento,
trae consigo la conclusión que
Pojman pone en cursivas en Kant:
"quien haya cometido un
asesinato debe morir".
No estoy segura si las cursivas
aparecen en el texto original
en alemán, pero sirven para
hacer el texto efectivo,
para quienes vuelven de las vacaciones
y buscan una llamada de aviso
para hacer sus lecturas.
La idea de que el merecido moral
exige una represalia de un tipo,
que la retribución del daño
trae consigo el mandato
de que se haga un daño
similar sobre ustedes,
tiene una forma especial en
la idea de Kant.
La idea de que se debe matar
a quien comete un asesinato
ha parecido a muchos una forma de
venganza y no de retribución.
Quiero presentarles un buen análisis,
al que se aludía en una de nuestras
lecturas, de Robert Nozick,
a quien ya hemos leído y
volveremos a leer.
Nozick ofrece un buen análisis sobre la
diferencia entre la retribución,
por un lado, y la venganza, por otro.
Quiero que tengan una imagen muy clara
de lo que significa la idea
de la retribución.
Un eje con el que se puede comparar
la retribución y la venganza
es qué genera el deseo de retribución.
Nozick dice que la
retribución es provocada
por un mal legal o moral, por la
violación de un código
que es aceptado por todas las partes,
pero que ha sido violado por alguien,
mientras que la venganza puede
ocurrir como respuesta a un daño
o a un agravio, no a una violación
del código moral como tal.
Nozick dice que hay límites
para la retribución.
Kant acaba de explicar una
versión de eso.
En la idea kantiana
sancionamos exactamente en la misma
proporción del daño hecho.
Por el contrario, la venganza es,
en principio, ilimitada.
En términos de la personalidad
implicada, el grado de personalización,
la retribución es impersonal,
la ejecuta el Estado.
Recuerden que esa era una de
nuestras caracterizaciones,
uno de los elementos de nuestra
caracterización del castigo.
Mientras que la venganza es personal.
La realiza un individuo
para expresar su insatisfacción.
La retribución tiene un tono
emocional distinto al de la venganza.
Cuando uno participa en la retribución,
uno disfruta de la justicia en sí misma
o no experimenta ningún sentimiento.
Cuando se encarcela a alguien,
se siente un placer por haber hecho lo
correcto, según la justicia,
pero no se siente placer por ver
sufrir a la otra persona.
Hay un tipo de generalidad que se
adscribe a la retribución.
Un individuo que realiza
un acto particular
en una circunstancia
particular, sea quien sea,
merecerá una retribución.
Mientras que en la venganza,
se trata de una persona específica
en un momento específico,
no de un caso de una categoría, sino
de un malhechor particular ante los ojos
de quien realiza la venganza.
La retribución y la
venganza son similares
en el hecho de que ambas son
actos expresivos.
En ambos casos,
el destinatario debería saber por
qué se le impone el castigo
y saber que se espera que lo sepa.
Voy a poner estas
diapositivas en Internet
por si no pudieron apuntar
todos los detalles.
Pero la idea de la
retribución que nos interesa
es la que está a la izquierda.
Quiero hablar de 2 casos donde esta
condición del conocimiento
genera situaciones potencialmente
sorprendentes o desconcertantes.
Una en el caso de la venganza y otra
en el caso de la retribución.
Como ya saben, es un
tropo de los cómics
que el villano siempre
intenta matar al héroe
y el héroe sabe el porqué.
Los que conocen a Austin Powers
saben que siempre logra
escaparse del Dr. Maligno,
porque el Dr. Maligno
está muy preocupado
por lo que podríamos pensar sobre
la restricción publicitaria
o el papel expresivo de la venganza.
Pero además de servir como argumento
para películas de parodias,
el fenómeno de que la
retribución implica
una forma especial de causar daño
plantea un fenómeno desconcertante
que podríamos llamar "justicia
hasta el fin del mundo".
Nozick escribe: "las condiciones que
delimitan la retribución
explican lo que de otra forma
parecería un fenómeno ridículo.
Si alguien condenado a muerte
se enferma gravemente
o intenta suicidarse, la
ejecución se pospone
y se toman medidas para sanar a
la persona condenada,
para que después pueda ser ejecutada.
Porque su castigo implica
que otros individuos lo ejecuten
debido a su mala acción.
Su muerte por causas naturales
o por su propia mano evitaría eso,
así que se toman medidas para
restablecerlo y poder castigarlo."
Noten cómo esto
establece un paralelismo
con el debate del caso del
niño ahogándose,
en el texto del Utilitarismo de Mill
y el de Fundamentos de Kant.
Mill solo está interesado en
sacar al niño del agua,
en ese pasaje no le interesa si
lo hacen por lucirse
para impresionar a alguien que
está en la orilla,
o si intentan conseguir una
recompensa económica
o expresar un cierto tipo de
compromiso moral.
Kant está interesado en
por qué lo hacen.
Aquí también.
En la idea de la
retribución lo que importa
no es que el delincuente muera de
cualquier forma al final.
Lo que importa es que el
delincuente muera
o sea castigado de la forma
correcta, al final,
como resultado de un proceso particular.
Concluiremos la clase de hoy
y continuaremos con el
utilitarismo en la siguiente
clase
con la cita desconcertante al
final del texto de Kant,
que ahora ya están en la
posición de comprender.
Kant dice que si fuera 2012 y el
mundo se fuera a acabar,
como pasa en esa película, y las olas
se acercan, caen relámpagos
y está comenzando una
nueva era de hielo,
lo primero que tienen que hacer,
antes de que el mundo se acabe,
es ejecutar a todos los
condenados a pena de muerte.
"Incluso si la sociedad civil
decide disolverse,
el último asesino que quede en
prisión debería ser ejecutado.
Esto debe hacerse".
Esta es la noción retributiva
"todos deben recibir su
merecido por sus hechos".
El jueves retomaremos la
justificación utilitaria del
castigo.
Nos vemos el jueves.